[Musik]
debatte und kooperation mit der linken
in der union tobt nach der thüringen
wahl ein richtungsstreit das
bundeskriminalamt schlägt alarm
jugendliche verbreiten online immer
öfter videos von kindesmissbrauch und
zunehmende gewalt im amateurfußball
schiedsrichter streiken und ein spieler
schlägt den unparteiischen bewusstlos
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten amt und ein
herzliches willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem montag
den sport in der sendung präsentierte
nah beieinander von mir
turbulente wahlnachlese heute in berlin
wir beginnen mit einem der wahlsieger
der linken und einem der verlierer der
cdu teile der union sind geradezu
entsetzt weil ihr thüringer
spitzenkandidat mohring jetzt gespräche
mit der linken führen möchte nachdem
niemand mit der erstarkten fdp regieren
will bleiben in thüringen sonst auch
kaum alternativen
das vorläufige endergebnis sieht so aus
die linke ist mit 31 prozent erstmals
stärkste kraft in einem bundesland die
afg kann ihr ergebnis mehr als
verdoppeln auf 23 4 prozent
die cdu rutscht ab auf 21,8 die spd auf
8,2 die grünen 5,2 und die fdp wieder im
landtag mit gerade fünf prozent für eine
regierungsmehrheit gibt es nur zwei
denkbare konstellationen entweder zum
bisherigen bündnis aus linken spd und
grünen kommt noch die fdp dazu was sie
schon ausgeschlossen hat oder linke und
cdu kommt zusammen was ein cdu
parteitagsbeschluss eigentlich nicht
zulässt cornelia schien es so viel zu
feiern hatten die linken schon lange
nicht mehr bodo ramelow fährt einem
erdrutschsieg ein
wo führt und beklatscht von der bundes
partei nun will der ministerpräsident
mit allen demokratisch gewählten
parteien reden auf und ausdrücklich mit
der cdu
warum sollten wir nicht mit einem neuen
kraftvollen zeichen auch aus thüringen
sagen politik ist vielfältiger als immer
nur in parteizentralen darüber zu reden
wer mit wem eventuell für die nächste
zeit verantwortung übernehmen kann
allein der gedanke auch nur an ein
gespräch mit den linken kommt bei
manchen in der union einem tabubruch
gleich wenn wir egal mit links oder mit
der linkspartei oder mit der afg
koalieren würden dann braucht es uns
nicht mehr
ganz gleich wie die situation sind es
gibt momente da ist haltung gefragt vor
der cdu-präsidiumssitzung dann blümchen
für den spitzenkandidaten und lächeln
für die kameras als die schließlich
draußen sind wird ordentlich gestritten
über den umgang mit den linken
schließlich bekräftigt die bundes-cdu
einem parteitagsbeschluss wonach
koalitionen mit linkspartei und afd
ausgeschlossen sind auch für mike
mohring dürfte das die rote linie sein
aber der thüringer hält sich ein türchen
offen zunächst für das land miteinander
zu sprechen
das ist glaube ich jetzt wichtiger als
parteipolitische erwägungen zu erzielen
und deswegen gehe ich mit aufmerksamen
aber offenen herzen in diese gespräche
hätten es ist im grunde genommen auch
eine parlamentarische
selbstverständlichkeit das nehmen wir
zur kenntnis
alles andere wird sich in den nächsten
wochen zeigen
annegret kramp karrenbauer sieht man den
druck deutlich an unter dem sie steht
parteien gerne kritiker machen auch sie
für das wahldebakel verantwortlich
annegret kramp karrenbauer ist nicht die
einzige die hier im mittelpunkt der
kritik zu stehen hat sondern es gibt
auch andere und das gesamte
erscheinungsbild der deutschen
bundesregierung ist einfach
grottenschlecht und daran muss ich etwas
ändert
die linke sieht den gesprächen erst
einmal ruhig entgegen und warnt vor zu
vielen rechnerischen debatten
es geht ja auch beim regieren ehrlich
gesagt um inhalte und die dürfe man
nicht ganz vergessen und bodo ramelow
kann sich zurücklehnen er hat ein
gesprächsangebot unterbreitet der ball
liegt nun im feld der union
die vertrackte lage nach der wahl in
thüringen sehen die anderen parteien
sehr unterschiedlich je nach
ausgangslage die afg feiert den
gewaltigen zuwachs über den knapp
gelungenen wiedereinzug freut sich die
fdp dagegen lecken die einzigen
regierungspartner spd und grüne ihre
wunden und suchen nach gründen für die
niederlage
nicole diekmann schönreden ablenken von
schlechten ergebnissen ein üblicher
reflex in der politik das ging heute
nicht mehr bei der spd zur mager die
acht prozent in thüringen
den sozialdemokraten bleibt nur die
hoffnung aus dem tal demnächst wieder
aufzusteigen zu einer starken spd werden
und der prozess ist momentan laufen da
führt aber auch dazu dass natürlich
viele menschen im moment auch darauf
warten wir wissen jetzt eigentlich ein
neuer parteivorsitz und wo ist die
orientierung schlechte ergebnisse wegen
der beschäftigung mit sich selbst
beschäftigung mit sich selbst wegen
schlechter ergebnisse und nun auch noch
neuer zündstoff für den
innerparteilichen streit über einen
verbleib in der gruppe weiterhin viele
fragezeichen bei der spd eine gewissheit
allerdings gibt es heute in berlin
niemand will mit der fdp koalieren
spitzenkandidat röcke gehört zu den
führenden figuren des rechtsextremen
parteiflügels der wird vom
verfassungsschutz als verdacht zwei
beobachtet die sorge der flüge gegner in
der afg höcker mache nun seinen
machtanspruch geltend und rücke die
partei weiter nach rechts wird heute
kleingeredet
ich freue mich grundsätzlich über
wettbewerbs weil wettbewerb einer
gesellschaft auch einer partei immer gut
tut und wenn wir auch einen
innerparteilichen wettbewerb um position
machen dann finde ich das erfreulich
keine koalition mit der afg und im falle
der liberalen auch keine mit der linken
fdp chef lindner erneuerte heute seine
koalitionsabsage seine partei schaffte
es ebenso wie die grünen gerade so in
den thüringer landtag
wer mit wem wer nicht mit wem wer gegen
wen die wahl in thüringen hat viel
durcheinander gewirbelt auch hier in
berlin
schauen wir noch mal auf die
bundesregierung theo koll in berlin die
parteien berg rocco wurden massiv
abgestraft in thüringen was bedeutet das
für die arbeit und stabilität der
regierung nun auf jeden fall ist
thüringen ein weiterer beleg dafür dass
die große koalition ein aderlass für
beide parteien bedeutet vor allem
natürlich bei der spd dürfte die skepsis
weiter zunehmen denn die
sozialdemokraten verlieren ja als
juniorpartner in der großen meister im
grunde müsste die union jetzt olaf
scholz sehr weit entgegenkommen in den
verhandlungen um die grundrente mit dem
ziel ihn in der stichwahl um den
spd-vorsitz unterstützen denn nur unter
einem spd chef scholz hätte die groko
eine art bestandsgarantie das aber wäre
für viele in der union einen extrem
hoher preis für den gegenwert einer
allseits ungeliebten großen koalition
apropos cdu wie sehr brodelt es dort
nach diesem dämpfer auch bei der
parteichefin
nun wenn man dem bild bleiben will
könnte man sagen es brodelt massiv
einerseits weil der köchin kramp
karrenbauer oft etwas überkocht
andererseits aber auch weil diverse
unions herren gerne ständig brennholz
nachlegen die machtfrage also wer in der
politischen küche der cdu künftig das
sagen hat diese frage wird häufiger und
immer offener gestellt frau kramp
karrenbauer hat heute ja den
fehdehandschuh aufgenommen und alle
gegner aufgefordert aus der deckung zu
kommen
wer kanzlerkandidat werden wolle der
solle sich bitte schön jetzt melden
wenn die zündler aber nicht kneifen dann
steht der cdu bald ein neuer machtkampf
ins haus dankeschön für diese
einschätzung aus berlin theo koll fast
jeder vierte an der wahlurne in
thüringen hat afd gewählt das macht
vielen angst der zentralrat der jugend
zeigt sich besorgt die türkischen
gemeinden in deutschland sprechen von
einem alarmsignal für migranten
es sei zeit sich einzugestehen dass die
menschen die afg nicht trotz sondern
wegen ihrer rassistischen ideologie
wählen wie die menschen in thüringen das
ergebnis sehen zeigt daniela sonntag
wer regiert thüringen eine demokratische
denksportaufgabe mancher wähler heute
regelrecht erschrocken über das ergebnis
jetzt treibt mir schon klein schauer
über den rücken wenn ich das mit der afg
hier in thüringen sehe das ist schon
schon angekratzt ist ich glaube nicht
dass es nur protestwähler sind das
glaube ich nicht
ein bestimmter prozentsatz wird diese
ideologie gutheißen
die erhöhte ja was sie vertritt der
massive erfolg der afd
er sorgt für schwierige verhältnisse in
thüringen und wahrscheinlich neue
experimente im landtag wahlsieger bodo
ramelow kennt sich damit aus und sieht
sogar chancen wenn es dazu dient das
dass wir die aufgaben lösen auch zu
neuen politik modellen werden dann wäre
das auch gut für die demokratie in
deutschland
aber wie und mit wem während cdu chef
mike mohring zumindest mit bodo ramelow
sprechen will rufen erste stimmen in der
partei schon nach einer zusammenarbeit
mit der fdp koalieren mit beiden dabei
unwahrscheinlich auch spd grüne und fdp
suchen nach neuen ideen für die
schwierige regierungsbildung thüringen
könnte eine andere art von
parlamentarische zusammenarbeit
entwickeln
die größte herausforderung besteht darin
bestehen dass die akteure sich
vielleicht doch auf dieses experiment
einer minderheitsregierung einlassen
dass sie versuchen einen landtag zu
konstituieren dem ist tatsächlich
möglich ist von sachfragen zu sachfrage
wechselnde mehrheiten zu finden
wenn das gelingt dann
vielleicht tatsächlich ein neues modell
zum regieren
und bis es soweit ist kann der
amtierende ministerpräsident
geschäftsführend im amt bleiben die
landesverfassung schreibt keine christen
vor zum wechselt die eu-staaten haben
großbritannien eine weitere verschiebung
des brh exit gewehrt jetzt bis zum 31
januar london darf aber auch früher
austreten
ob und wann das passieren kann es noch
immer unklar prämie johnson will heute
abend über eine neuwahl am 12 dezember
abstimmen lassen
es gilt aber als unwahrscheinlich dass
er dafür die nötige zwei drittel
mehrheit bekommt es ist das ende einer
ära nach acht jahren scheidet mario
draghi aus dem amt des präsidenten der
europäischen zentralbank bei einem
festakt in frankfurt würdigten
europäische spitzenpolitiker den
italiener für seine rolle bei der
euro-rettung seine bis heute andauernde
nullzinspolitik wird aber auch kritisch
gesehen
tragisches nachfolgerin wird die
französin christine lagarde in
argentinien kehrt die linke zurück an
die macht bei der präsidentschaftswahl
haben die wähler die konservative
regierung abgestraft und den kandidaten
der opposition fernandez ins amt gewählt
das votum ist auch ein comeback für ex
präsidentin kirchner zitiert als
stellvertreterin zurück an die macht
trotz massiver korruptionsvorwürfe
argentinien durchleidet die schlimmste
wirtschaftskrise seit 17 jahren
[Musik]
es ist eine der hässlichsten seiten der
smartphone-welt auf die das
bundeskriminalamt heute aufmerksam macht
jugendliche die über ihre handys videos
mit vergewaltigungen von kindern
verbreiten im klassen chat offenbar ohne
sich gedanken zu machen
der missbrauchsbeauftragte der
bundesregierung fordert deswegen ein
pflichtfach medienkompetenz an den
schulen
im konkreten fall geht es um 21
verdächtige im alter zwischen 14 und 26
laut den ermittlern tauschen immer mehr
jugendliche bilder und videos die
sexuelle gewalt gegen kinder zeigen
susanne santana berichtet
hey jungs zieht euch das hier mal rein
was die beiden mit der kleinen machen
jack mal dass hier die jungs im
kinderzimmer sind viel krasser unterwegs
es sind solche kommentare die über whats
app instagram und andere soziale
netzwerke gelegt und verbreitet werden
die das bundeskriminalamt auf den plan
rufen denn es geht um videos die
schwerste sexuelle missbräuche von
kindern zeigen
es hat sich verändert die
leichtsinnigkeit mit der kinder
jugendliche mit diesem material umgehen
und natürlich spielt auch die kindliche
neugier eine rolle die hier dazu führt
dass sich kinder auch vor der kamera
selber produzieren
letzte woche waren die wohnungen von
insgesamt 21 beschuldigten in elf
bundesländern durchsucht worden
es geht um die verbreitung von zwei
bestimmten videos die zum einen den real
missbrauch eines zirka zehn jahre alten
jungen vermutlich im ausland zeigen
der real missbrauch meint damit die
vergewaltigung dieses zehnjährigen
jungen durch zwei weitere jugendliche in
dem anderen video müssen zwei kinder
sexuelle handlungen gegenseitig an sich
ausüben
kinder leiden durch den sexuellen
missbrauch ein leben lang was die
verbreitung ihrer bilder im internet
zusätzlich für sie bedeute sei vielen
beschuldigten nicht klar
sie müssen davon ausgehen dass es nicht
nur in deutschland verbreitet wird
sondern weltweit international
millionenfach und was einmal im netz ist
extrem schwierig eigentlich unmöglich zu
entfernen allein in deutschland gab es
im letzten jahr rund 70.000 hinweise auf
verbreitung von bildern und videos mit
kinderpornografie schlägereien
schiedsrichter attacken spielabbrüche
deutschlands amateur fußball hat ein
zunehmendes gewaltproblem opfer sind oft
die schiedsrichter so wurde in der
letzten saison in berlin jeder siebte
unparteiische mindestens einmal
angegriffen deshalb streikten jetzt in
der hauptstadt die schiedsrichter
gleichzeitig schlug ein kreisligaspieler
in hessen einen referee krankenhausreif
nina kuscheligen kreisliga dieburg
südhessen fsv münster gegen tv semd es
steht 0 2 dann schlägt ein fsv spieler
wegen einer gelb roten karte voll zu der
22 jährige schiedsrichter fällt
bewusstlos zu boden
der täter läuft einfach vom platz
der mann wird jetzt als beschuldigter in
einem strafverfahren geführt es wurde
eine anzeige wegen körperverletzung
erstattet gewalt gegen schiedsrichter im
amateurbereich längst kein einzelfall
mehr
in der letzten saison gab es laut dfb
2906 angriff auf unparteiische in
insgesamt sechs 1291 spielen gab es
gewalt oder diskriminierung man hat
immer weggeguckt und hat gesagt das wird
sich schon irgendwie erledigt wurde wir
können da nichts machen das sind
gesellschaftliche fehlentwicklungen
pustekuchen es gibt keine tabus mehr es
kann der kleinste fehlpass die kleinsten
entscheidung dazu führen dass die leute
ausrasten dass die schiedsrichter
attackiert werden in berlin blieben
deshalb am wochenende fast alle
fußballplätze leer
denn die schiris wollten ein zeichen
setzen wegen ihres streiks fanden 1500
spiele nicht statt
der dfb äußert sich nur schriftlich zur
zunehmenden gewalt gegen schiris
einblick in jeder tageszeitung genügt um
zu sehen dass gewalt ein problem in
unserer gesamten gesellschaft und damit
nicht ein alleiniges des fußballs ist
der fußball ist auch hier ein
spiegelbild der gesellschaft
der verletzte schiedsrichter in münster
wurde nach der tat per
rettungshubschrauber in eine klinik
gebracht er ist bei bewusstsein soll
jedoch schwierigkeiten haben zu sprechen
damit sie immer bei dir norbert unter
formel 1 ja und dort lewis hamilton
einen großen schritt in richtung wm
titelverteidigung gemacht gestern abend
gewann er den grand prix von mexiko vor
sebastian vettel ferrari mit den
schnelleren autos mercedes aber mit der
besseren strategie lewis hamilton ist
seinem sechsten wm-titel ganz nahe und
ferrari schafft es zum dritten mal in
dieser saison nicht die startplätze eins
und zwei ins ziel zu bringen
der kritischste moment mit einem
rutscher nach einer leichten berührung
mit verstappen danach jedoch passt alles
ein boxenstopp zum richtigen zeitpunkt
bei mercedes piloten
auch sebastian vettel und sein ferrari
team mit der ein stopp strategie
zu spät jedoch geht er auf die harte
reifenmischung danach liegt hamilton an
der spitze und gibt diese bis ins ziel
nicht mehr her
vettel zeigt sich nicht unzufrieden mit
dem zweiten platz meint aber hier und da
hätten wir etwas mehr cleverness zeigen
müssen
so darf hamilton eine fiesta mexicana
genießen
die wird sich nicht verstecken müssen
hinter seiner wahrscheinlich folgenden
titelfeier kommenden sonntag
jan lennard struff hat beim atp
tennisturnier in paris die zweite runde
erreicht der 29 jahre alte wahl- steine
besiegte den japaner yoshito nishioka in
drei sätzen mit 4 6 7 5 6 zu 2 ein
harter kampf der fast zwei stunden
dauerte
jan lennard struff erleichtert er nutzte
seinen zweiten matchball und gewinnt
eine nervenaufreibende partie gegen
japanischen qualifikanten yoshito und
joker doch erst nach einer challenge
wackler dieser punkt zum 6 2 und dritten
satz geht an den 29 jährigen deutschen
nach drei hart umkämpften sätzen im
ersten war der japaner noch mit 5 zu 1
davon gezogen
struck musste attackieren und tartes die
nummer 36 der welt gewann den zweiten
satz knapp mit 7 zu 5 und ließ im
dritten keinen zweifel an seinem
siegeswillen aufkommen
der deutsche bekommt es in der zweiten
runde von paris nun mit dem russischen
titelverteidiger cara chan abzutun und
das war's auch schon familie in drei
tagen ist halloween genau und dann
stehen wieder haufenweise kleine monster
vor der tür doch weil das saubere
zunehmend ausartet greift die polizei
buchung jetzt selbst in die trickkiste
und appelliert per grusel video sicht
nicht daneben zu benehmen
bei einem anderen helau wenigsten prügel
androht oder in den großen kollegen den
süßigkeiten wegnimmt wie mit juristisch
einen raub und somit ein verbrechen
gedreht wurde mit utensilien wie ein
halloween begeisterter kollege von zu
hause mitgebracht hat hat und spaß
gemacht denn die beamten wollen künftig
häufiger solche videos drehen
noch zum wetter regen gibt es morgen
wieder südlich der donau im norden
dagegen wechseln sonne und wolken die
details hat gleich gunther tiersch
marietta slomka begrüßt sie um viertel
vor zehn im heute journal
danke für ihr interesse haben sie noch
einen entspannten abend und bis morgen
wenn sie mögen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
mit namen liebe zuschauer bis zum
freitag bleibt es bei uns auch ziemlich
kühle temperaturen in mitteleuropa um
die zehn grad noch kälter ist in
skandinavien winterlich
höchsttemperaturen minus zehn grad da
schneit es bis ins baltikum und dann
haben wir diese temperaturgrenze über
frankreich den alpen und ungarn südlich
davon wärme von 20 bis 25 grad
und diese grenze wird gebildet durch
wolken und regen diesen regen haben wir
eben auch heute nacht noch an den alpen
sonst bildet sich nebel in der mitte
deutschlands im norden gibt es
vielleicht an der ostsee und da noch
regenschauer und es wird auch frostig
zumindest in der lüneburger heide minus
1 grad wahrscheinlich morgen wechseln in
norddeutschem sonne und wolken aber nach
osten hin
mit diesem jahr mäßige nordostwind geht
hier und da kleinere regenschauer in
süddeutschland dagegen na ja da ist es
ein bisschen bewölkter nebel hochnebel
und dann die wolken die über den süden
nach osten ziehen und an den alpen immer
noch regen bringen der langsam auch
wieder nachlässt tagsüber und es lockert
von nordwesten wieder ein bisschen auf
die temperaturen
sie sind noch ein bisschen niedriger als
heute sechs bis zehn grad hier im westen
haben niederrhein bis 12 grad und so
geht es eigentlich auch weiter mit sonne
und nebel am freitag kommt da ein
kräftiger regen im westen auf und es
wird langsam wieder milder ihnen noch
einen schönen abend und machen sie es
gut